We have SIS module, we have fee module, you have already given assignments for academics and attendance, right Tanvibha?
Guys, say yes or no.
Yes sir.
Now the point is that we have admission module.
But before using any module, as you know, we have the option to do its basic setup.
Whether it is your attendance, fee or SIS.
In SIS, you add student's fees and basic information.
In the case of fee, you make fee structure, add groups etc.
In the case of academics, you make subjects and do subject class mapping.
Similarly, in the case of admission, I give an overview.
When you come here, you have admission module, where you have the application data page, admission leads page.
If we have done any transaction during that particular admission, it will be shown in the transaction.
Then we have admission reports.
You have multiple reports in reports, we will do it in detail.
Then you have the follow-up page.
So whatever follow-up you add in any lead, it has a separate page to check the follow-up.
Furthermore, we have admission lead logs.
In lead logs, if your IVR is integrated, i.e. if your callings are integrated,
then you will receive the respective IVR calls directly in the ERP.
Let me switch the session once.
So you also get callings like this.
Call came, received, missed call, no one picked, no one's name came.
So all the things remain in the admission.
But before that, we will do the basic part, the advanced part.
Whatever admission site you do, here we have,
any lead moves from multiple stages and gets admission.
When you have also taken admission, then your counselling will be done,
then you must have submitted the fee, right?
Then your admission will be done, right?
So for every institute, we have different stages.
Is it clear? Tanvi Babu and Amit Sir?
Yes sir.
So basically what happens is, any particular lead that you have,
it moves from multiple stages.
First the lead will come, the counsellor will work on it.
After working on it, it goes to the data requested stage,
then it goes to the prospectus stage, right?
After that, it does the registration, then payment is done.
So for every entity, there are different ways to set it up.
There is a prospectus fee somewhere, there is a registration fee somewhere, right?
There is no such stage anywhere.
So the lead comes, after the lead comes, you have directly approved it.
So it depends on the client requirement.
So when you come to this page, the application leads page,
then you have stages here.
For example, in this entity, you have the lead stage,
the data requested stage, the registration stage and the approved stage.
Let me show you another entity.
So I have another entity available in admission.
In that, the stages we have are different.
In their case, the application is submitted,
then they have the document uploaded to the children,
the counsellor verifies the document,
then the academic admin or academic person verifies it,
then we allot the transport to the children.
Then your leads are approved or rejected.
Is that point clear?
In the case of every entity, the stages could be different.
Getting my point?
Yes, that's correct.
Now the point is, where does all this setup happen?
For example, in the case of academics,
in the case of institute setup,
similarly we have admissions setup.
When you click on the admission setup, you have two things.
One is your admission master, then you have the stage setup.
First of all, I will go to the admission master and tell you the basics.
Then we will come to the stage setup.
If you remember, when you did the student setup,
there was a reg number setup.
That means giving a unique number to the student.
Say admission number or reg number.
Am I right?
Who can do that?
Yes sir.
Similarly, we have to give a number to your application.
For example, application form number.
If you don't give it a number, how will you identify it?
To set up a number, in the master setup,
we have the application number setup.
You will click on it.
For which course, you have to keep a separate numbering,
prefix or suffix, you can keep that.
For the program, you can keep it separate.
For example, I have kept school of engineering,
I want specific in that too, so you can keep that.
If you do all, then for all the courses,
whether it is school or college,
in both the cases, it will be similar.
The process is almost similar,
it is just a little advanced in the case of college or university.
From here, you have to add its prefix or suffix.
You have added the prefix, you have added the number,
from where it will start and you have added the suffix.
As the leads will be added,
our system will automatically give them numbering.
Is it okay?
One lead is added, it gets a number.
Another lead is added, it gets another number.
In this sequence, this counter will be auto-updated.
For example, how much is going on here?
Your total leads have come here.
And the counter that is going on here is going on.
So automatically, the counter,
if one more lead is added, then it will be 48.
If one more is added, then it will be 49.
So this counter will be automatically updated.
Now coming back,
what happens after that?
Now you have to set up a stage,
from which stage a lead has to move and go.
So in this case, what we do,
here we have a stage master setup.
We have set up the application number.
After that, the stage master sets up
the stages that we need.
So after clicking on the stage master,
we have three stages,
which are by default, which are at the back end.
If you uncheck it, then it will be added.
If you uncheck it, then it will be removed.
For example, it has approved and rejected.
Approved and rejected is the last stage.
We don't make it.
These three stages come from the back end.
We don't make them ourselves.
We have to make any stage,
so for now, I am taking an example.
If I want to make any stage,
I will click on add new.
I have accepted the fresh setup.
I have only approved and rejected.
After that, I have named my stage in the enter value.
Then I have to make another stage.
I will name it.
So here we make stages.
First of all, application submission.
Then our document is uploaded.
So our document is being uploaded here.
If there is a counselor doc verification,
then there is a counselor doc verification.
If there is an academic doc verification,
then there is an academic doc verification.
Last but not least, we have
transport and hostel selection.
So we have transport and hostel selection.
Is this clear? Why are we doing it? How are we doing it?
Guys.
Yes sir.
This is done.
After this is done,
you have a source part here.
I will not go in advance for now.
We have a source part.
Now basically, if you know,
the leads that come for admission,
they can come from multiple sources.
If you have a direct walk-in,
if you have an ad from a newspaper,
if you have a Google ad,
or if you are running any kind of
meta ads or something,
whatever you have done,
those are sources.
From which sources do you get data?
So in general, schools and colleges,
if there is a high-end college,
then they have multiple things.
They get traffic from their websites,
from their landing pages.
If they have some third-party integrations,
like college duniya,
college dekho,
then all that is there.
In general, while setting up,
online or offline or walk-in is direct.
You can manually add this
from here, add new details.
There is a reference field here.
What happens in the case of reference,
if you turn on the reference source,
then while adding the lead,
I will show you.
Sources, reference.
What will come in this?
We will have to check if it will come in this or not.
So what happens in the case of reference,
we have two more that are added.
In which you can put a reference,
from which reference this lead came from.
Getting my point?
So sources are what,
or from which source do you get data?
So while adding the lead, you select that too.
Tell me one thing, this much part is clear,
application number setup is clear,
state setup is clear?
Yes sir.
Now what happens,
from any application,
like I have viewed this application,
after viewing that application,
at that stage,
some specific fields are visible to me.
Student's name, student's email,
student's phone number, student's gender.
Multiple fields are there related to
the father detail, mother detail.
Where will you set all these things?
Because if you are getting student's admission,
then you will get some basic information
in its basic fields.
Add setup.
Now where does your
field setup stay?
You will come back here,
in the master,
in the admission setup,
it is called stage setup.
You will click on stage setup.
Suppose there is no stage
added here.
So I have an option to directly copy
from my old sessions,
I can copy the stages.
Second, I can create a new one here,
I am clicking on add stage setup.
After add stage setup,
like all these are already made,
the ones that I have already made,
so because of this, they are grayed out.
Let's do one thing,
let's create one.
Add testing,
save it,
I have come to stage setup,
I have clicked on add stage setup.
Now see, the one that was not selected
anywhere in the table,
it is coming here for selection.
I will click on stage setup.
Now our stage sequence
will come,
like our application submission
is in the first sequence,
here the data is in the first sequence.
Our
document uploader
is in the second sequence,
so we will give it a sequence of 5,
because our 4 is already added.
Then you have a type,
stage type,
lead or application.
What does lead mean?
Initially, the ones that come first,
when there is no work on fresh leaders,
we consider it as lead type.
For now, just understand that
it is a very advanced thing,
just understand that I have a fresh lead,
if it is getting hit at any stage,
that is the lead stage for me.
Later,
work has started on it,
some further councilor took action,
whatever that lead will be,
that stage will go to your application stage.
Stage type is its application.
Furthermore,
we have a select councilor option here.
Basically,
being an admin,
I have all the data,
but in the case of
this entity,
data came, application submission came,
councilor moved,
from here to next stage,
next stage has an option to move,
you will pay from here,
move to next stage.
After payment,
when it comes to next stage,
like document upload stage,
now I have to move to councilor verification,
so I moved from here,
it will come to councilor verification.
When I update it,
add some values,
then I will move it to academic doc verification.
Now the point is,
you cannot show all the data
to the academic person.
Do you understand the point?
Just understand that
there is a file,
it is passing through multiple tables.
Table A was there,
as a person,
who is coordinating things,
he can see everything.
But the point is,
until that thing goes to that stage,
he cannot see anything.
Do you understand?
So what I will do,
I will set a stage councilor here.
Like we have done in this case,
your academic doc verification,
I have tagged a person here,
in this case,
we have tagged Manna sir.
So basically what will happen,
as soon as some application
will come to that stage,
in which you have set the councilor,
then only that person will see that application,
before that,
his whole screen will be blank.
Only these cards will come,
no values will come,
no applications will come.
As soon as a councilor moves to that stage,
where that person is tagged,
then that application will be visible.
Do you understand?
Assume that I have 4 tables,
the first file came to the first table,
moved to the second,
Tanvi is sitting on the third table.
Now I have tagged Tanvi,
he will come to the third table only.
Before that, he cannot see anything.
So this is similar to that,
if you have a table there,
I have tagged a person on that table,
when that file will reach that person,
only then it will be visible,
before that, it will not be visible.
Is it clear or not?
Amit sir, is it clear to you?
It is a little clear,
when that file will be visible,
when that stage...
What I mean to say is,
that lead will be visible only
when that person reaches that stage.
Before that, all the stages will be blank,
nothing will be visible to him.
But if you are an admin,
then it will be visible to you.
That's it.
We will give a role to the counselor,
according to that.
Okay, guys, this part is clear.
After that, what we have here,
these are the preferences,
communication preferences,
that as soon as an application
reaches this stage,
it will have a message,
you can select a template from that.
Whatever template we have made in communication,
we have communication,
when you will do it, do it.
Then you have WhatsApp,
if you want to send WhatsApp to a student,
you can select WhatsApp,
if you want to send an email, you have email.
So as soon as you select all this,
then automatically any lead,
as soon as it moves,
the counselor moves,
then the system,
an email that you have selected in it,
an SMS that you have selected in it,
or a WhatsApp that you have selected in it,
it will be automatically triggered.
You will not need to send it manually.
Is this clear?
Is it clear, guys?
Good.
After that, we come to the next stage.
There is no WhatsApp template, so I am turning it off.
We come to the next stage.
Now we have all the fields.
Basically, by default,
nothing is shown to you,
but I have already made it,
so it is coming.
So now what field do you want to keep at that stage?
Basically, what happens is that
we do not keep all the fields at every stage.
Because suppose there is the first stage.
In the first stage, we need basic information.
We will get that.
Later, when we collect the documents,
we will collect other things,
we will take its schooling-related information.
We add all those fields further.
Do you understand? Is this clear?
Yes, sir.
Similarly, in the case of the stage,
you can add fields from here.
You can also copy the field.
Suppose you made the old stage below,
the stage that was coming at the bottom,
you can also copy it from here.
Look at one thing.
In academic doc verification,
I have 28 fields.
In the application submission,
I have 141 fields.
Counselor has 26.
In document upload, 30.
In transport, we do not need much,
because we have already collected all the information at the stage.
So I have kept 5 fields
to see the basic information.
Because why keep the page loaded
where there is no requirement for anything?
So I clicked on add stage setup.
I selected testing here.
I gave 5 number sequencing.
I selected other things from here.
You will not do it, it will work.
This is a specific case in which you have to do it.
Then you will come to the next field,
like we came in this case.
And from here, you can also copy the field
from the existing one.
If you copy the stages below,
then automatically all the fields you put,
I will not do this one, I will do this one.
There are fewer fields.
So automatically my 5 fields that were added,
will be copied.
Do you understand guys?
Do you understand?
Yes sir.
After that,
what happens is,
you have to add another field.
If you have added 5 fields,
then click on add field.
You will get a drop down below.
Select whatever field you want.
Give its name.
If you want to keep it mandatory,
then toggle on mandatory from here.
What will be the type of the field?
Will there be a date? Will there be a select box?
If you keep a select box, then you can push values from here.
I will show you that one.
Let's consider it for gender.
So you can put multiple genders
Male, female.
Male, female, male.
What is happening?
And then others.
If you push it from here,
then your 3 options will be pushed.
Further,
if it is your phone number,
then you will set it as phone number.
If it is your file type, then you will set it as file type.
If it is toggle type, then you will set it as toggle type.
Usually, you just have to see
text, date, select box and fall.
You have to see this phone and this file.
Toggle edit doesn't happen anywhere.
Then what happens is,
I will show you one thing.
Every application,
every field comes in a group.
You get some things in personal details,
you get some things in document upload,
you get some things in address.
So how do we do this grouping?
So we have the option of group by.
What I did was, I selected 4-5 fields
and put them in transport detail.
So what will happen is, if you put them separately in hosted data,
then these two will come separately.
So what will the system do?
It will show it according to that group on this page.
Then you put the sequence number.
So there was no sequencing before this.
So what will the system do?
According to that sequence,
it goes to 1, 2, 3 or 4.
Before that, it was on 1,
this will go to 0, then on 1.
Then this sequencing will go.
So sequencing means that
it will be visible in the sequence you want to keep.
If I set it up now,
let's make it fresh.
I came to this.
Add field.
Suppose you don't have any stage,
then you will click on add multiple field.
Because you don't have enough time
to add one field from here and then another.
You don't have enough time.
Select multiple fields.
What do you want? Student's name, student's date, student's gender.
Student's phone number, email, address.
That's it.
It will depend on your requirement.
Now I am telling you the basics.
You have multiple fields.
You can select whatever you want.
As soon as you click on save,
all the fields will be added to you.
You can give them sequence numbers.
1, 2, 4.
You can give them any sequence number.
You can give sequence numbers to the field you want to show.
Next,
I will tell you the transaction one tomorrow.
Save it.
After saving, refresh it.
Then your stage will be added.
Your testing stage will be added.
Is it clear, guys?
Yes, sir.
Sir, tell me the difference between lead and application.
What happens in the case of lead?
In general,
I will tell you in advance.
I have two pages.
One is application data and one is admission leads.
If you want to show any application
on the leads page,
then you need to tag it as lead.
In general, the lead is
that nothing has been done on it.
It is fresh.
No data has been added.
No document request has been filled.
To keep it on that stage,
you have to set that stage as a lead stage.
In general,
your first stage,
the very first stage,
is the lead stage.
You have to set all the other applications.
Because you are taking only the data.
You have to do the work first.
Is it clear?
I will not go into too much detail.
Tell me the doubts in this.
Is there any doubt,
any question?
We have just done the stage part.
Amit sir, any doubt?
No, sir.
Clear.
Parvathan, any doubt?
Clear, sir.
Can I close, sir?
Thank you.
Thank you for your time.
Have a nice day.